like the guy who found fire good dude we  appreciate it you know what none of us  know his name did it matter sure does it  matter that that was his name and he was  the guy probably not when you look at  your towns that you live in and you see  like Henderson and Jacksonville these  guys were big deals and named cities  after themselves and we barely know and  you probably have areas in your city you  would aspire to have a street named  after you or an entire County named  after you Clark County but no one knows  who Clark I know Clark is right I live  here I think a lot of times we inflate  micro importance of things when in  reality they aren't important at all and  we just choose to make them meaningful  and then all of a sudden you just exit  the game of happy sad and get to be your  own game maker